this 3d microscope is one example of how
new tech can solve cold cases adopted by
Italy's forensic police unit is able to
analyze objects in higher definition
than its 2d counterparts helping to turn
old fingerprints or recovered bullets
into solid leads
according from 30 d-darling with the
analysis of fingerprints but at the time
was considered useless I can now use
modern 3d reconstruction graphics to
understand the dynamics of what's
happened at the scene of the crime but
re-examining the old evidence is only
part of cracking the case police also
have to find a suspect like who murdered
13 year old Yara gamba a CEO in 2010
using a new forensic technique called
touch DNA Italian police were able to
pick up microscopic traces of foreign
skin cells from the schoolgirls clothing
they then analyzed it against 22,000
people resulting in one match 44 year
old carpenter Massimo Giuseppe boss 30
these techniques are helping to shed
light on cases hindered by the passage
of time but experts a concern that touch
DNA cannot always provide accurate
results in some crime scenes all sort of
idea if someone touches an object I can
find the traces of DNA transferred from
that person's hand but it also could
have come from that person touching
another individual so it's essential to
evaluate how these traces got down in
the first place for these reasons the
DNA forensics has to be judged as
crucial evidence for it to be used in
Italian courts but even with these
limitations there's been some
breakthroughs despite bisetti denying
all charges the DNA evidence recovered
will be used against him in Yara gamba
ratios murder trial last year 28 old
cases were solved because of these new
forensic techniques and with over a
hundred investigations reopened these
technologies approving the Italian
justice does not easily forget the past
you